time to play against we play this last
week and people like they wanted to
bring it back so for those listening to
rest really we livestream this now so
there are all kinds of graphics and
things that you don't get to hear on
radio of course let me take this I hear
graphics on radio it's unbelievable so
uh not get you have a cued up we have a
cue now time to play it's total it was
gender pronouns
okay so this is the game out first some
disclaimers they're not actually
pronouns they're really just nouns but
we needed an extra syllable it was it
was critical for the song it was
critical for the song there's really
only three gender pronouns but these are
actual genders Dana did not get here
just pulled these I've never seen these
before so I'm gonna have to determine
whether wait a minute yeah he's going to
list the pronoun and then we're not not
the point on the gender and then you and
I are gonna have a chance to guess yes
three seconds to see the word that you
can guess three seconds dude or a chick
no no no you have to get it's a total
gender like I could be like like it
could be acqua gender there's there are
hundreds of genders that are they now
claim exist on tumblr look how
uneducated she looks right now I know
she has no idea she's not living in 2016
look at her she looks young she's got
the college in her face but her brain is
gone she doesn't mean she can't even
keep up with the gender to keep up can't
keep up I'm ashamed I call her my friend
so so we don't we don't classify it as
being a chick or a dude because that's
know yeah it's a whole other gender so
we're going this season noun and then
you have to guess and I have to guess
and then it will be determined by gender
Zordon you got the first one first one
okay
Kayle gender Kayle gender okay Danny you
got vegetable is that like four set like
kale like salad no okay is that your
guess that's our guess
my guess is kale Cael some sort of thing
that has to do with like elves and
attraction they like to dress up like
leafy greens there you go that's your
guess okay the answer is kale gender a
gender which shares qualities with outer
space or is aesthetic similar to space
stars nebulas etc okay so who's the
winner we need Zordon too we need uh
yeah I think we need a winner here and
I'm gonna go with
okay that seems biased that seems a
little biased face that I'll take it
alright not a loyal Zordon at all no all
right no what's okay give us another Gen
X 1 is 3 seconds ok
Jupiter gender oh this oh this I totally
feel like Stefan on SNL it's that thing
when you have a total fat person and
they don't you can't tell like maybe
it's back fat that you might think are
breast and you're not sure that's what
I'm going with well see the thing is I
would have guessed I would have guessed
the previous gender that had to do
similarities of space right planets
Jupiter okay no ha a second Jupiter
gender I'm gonna go with the it's it's
the gender of the model from Sports
Illustrated's test McNeil's chess
monsters gender orbit test monster right
I don't know she's got so many names and
so many tattoos and so many skin folds
ok here we are
the answer is Jupiter gender a gender
that is so large in present what is not
quite sure what it is because it's so
too big to see clearly but it is
definitely there and no one knows and
and one knows I'm not sis I think I was
closer okay so who what's the tiebreaker
what's everyone who wins that one that's
not that doesn't seem to none I don't
think I'm gonna win any of these I don't
think it's not looking good for you okay
alright these are real genders dance
know that this isn't a joke I use that
as a pejorative from here on out
Jupiter gender and shell gender okay
I'll let Danny go that seems pretty
obvious Dana
it's that thing when there's nothing in
your underpants oh okay I would say
someone who wants to you know get free
doesn't term for a eunuch I would say
someone who wants to get freaky with a
hermit crab shell and the answer is
shell gender a gender which is thin
though clearly identify and yet feels
Hollow
to unfilled you don't reflect the names
at all it says I think it's rigged
not even a show that's not even a show
that's just any kind of enclosed all
right who's the winner we'd have to pick
a winner though so that's not right
that's not right that is not right okay
do we have another one we do have
another one for no one
these these don't seem real these are
real jobs real from tumblr these are
real you swear I swear swear mother
that's where I know she's picky about
that she's fine I swear on your dad ah
I'll swear all day on them all right
here we go next what is he gender okay
well Dana you can go that's a person
that loves gasps no it's a it's a matrix
gases yeah I'm gonna go with someone who
is a fan of the Gracie lineage
specifically the Gracie Hume I oughta
Helio Gracie the famous of all the
Gracie's someone who has a fetish for
Gracie's I'm guessing or they like to
put a propeller on their butt and spin
it I don't know they like that no it is
a gender a gender that is warm and
burning like BD or something as opposed
to it you need to see a doctor I need to
see a doctor there's a rash accompany it
that sounds that all right just for
though that's not that's not a loyal
really disloyal zoran animal okay do we
have one more we did one more you let's
go one more yes
all right here we are next one is flower
gender well come on are you gonna trick
us with this this one seems relatively
oh yes I know maybe it's like what's the
opposite of a flower I don't know it's a
it's a person who they identify identify
as as plant life and they are attracted
a sexually to things that grow in
the word is short oh that's embarrassing
that's really in there sorry about that
Dana I think Dana's given the obvious
answer I think it's a gender of someone
who didn't truly blossom into their true
gender until later blossoming let's give
reference all right
flower gender flower gender gender that
is more strongly felt during the daytime
than at night not even right that's
based on the light so it's based on
photosynthesis as it's some sort of
science that we haven't quantified even
that science yet so we're working under
science gender synthesis
I don't know this doesn't seem is this
the last one this is last one we have to
Ward a winner for this round is not a
loyal steed do we have to play us out
for Dana and we do how to play us out
Dana thank you so much for playing we're
still gonna keep you but
Oh
there's there's none there's no sign if
you're watching this congratulations
you've not yet been corrupted by the
internet and your short attention span I
know mine went away with dramatic
hamster and then it was just solidified
with history of dance that guy could
really do the Ice Ice Baby here's the
thing you may not know this is a clip
from a full three hour radio show you
can see that full show by clicking next
to me I think there's something else
playing in another box it might be
another short video I don't know I can't
be bothered to do my research you're
still here